every champions road to the top is paved
with blood sweat and sacrifice and EA
sports UFC for the first time ever
before you get your arm raised to win
this title you'll have to start by
proving you're worthy of a number for
nearly a decade the ultimate fighter has
been a proving ground for MMA is elite
and before your UFC career can end up in
the Hall of Fame it's going to begin in
the top gym launch your career by
tailoring your look and skill base with
our extensive fighter creation system
featuring photo game face then it's time
to hit the gym hone the wrestling
grappling and striking skills in one of
the UFC's most revered training
facilities there you'll gather all the
tools you need to complete the
transformation from prospect to prodigy
dominate the tough tournament and claim
the coveted UFC contract along with the
title of the ultimate fighter your
long-term EA sports UFC career is based
on two rating systems popularity and
longevity bring your a-game put on
exciting fights and scored big finishes
to earn fans and watch a popularity
skyrocketing a day that goes by balance
to your face on magazines or on TV not
only will a high popularity rating
unlock sponsors whose gear you can then
we're in game as well as exclusive
fighter messages it'll also encourage
the UFC's biggest stars to visit your
camp with training tips before important
fights but my reckless lean absorb too
much punishment and your career
longevity meter will drop quicker than
if you fight intelligently like any
fighter you can only get your ticket
punched so many times and when your
longevity meter runs out with your
fighters careers over progressing
through your fighters career will also
earn you evolution and experience points
evolution points can be used towards
upgrading your fighters attributes and
moves allowing you to increase the power
of your left
or learn how to do the show topkick
experience points automatically go
towards leveling up your fighter which
worse to unlock abilities that can be
used to customize a game plan for your
upcoming fight there are three ability
categories stand up ground game and
physical ability and when added to a
game plan they give your fighter unique
performance boost in those areas
fighting smart makes all the difference
in EA sports UFC and over the course of
your career you can unlock multiple game
plans helping you to become a more
varied and dynamic fighter every
opponent is different and you'll have to
put together the right game plan if you
want to beat the best take the title and
fight your way into the UFC olive bank
feel the fight for yourself when EA
sports UFC drops jun 17
you